Knowing this two by two confusion
matrix is just the beginning.
There are many different metrics can be derived
from those basic metrics. In particular,
many metrics can be derived by taking ratios
of different numbers from this basic metrics.
First, let's introduce a set of metrics that are
derived by normalizing some terms with the ground
truth value, either the total population or the
condition positive or the condition negative.
All these metrics are defined by some
conative divided by those normalization terms.
For example, accuracy
is the ratio from the sum of true positive and
true negative divided by the total population.
Accuracy is the most basic metric that
many people have intuitive understanding,
but accuracy is not always the best measure when
the class label are very imbalanced. If only 1%
of the total population have heart failure, models
can be achieved 99% accuracy by simply predicting
everyone would not have heart failure. So, it
is important to use the appropriate metric for
measuring the performance of a predictive model.
Another important metric is true positive rate or
sensitivity or recall. They have different names,
because the same metric has been developed by
different communities, and true positive rate
equals the true positive divided by the
condition positive in the ground truth.
To explain the intuition, let's assume positive
means heart failure and negative means without
heart failure. The intuition of true positive rate
is to measure among all people with heart failure,
what percentage is correctly
identified by the predictive
model?
A very related metric can be derived called
false negative rate, which equals 1 minus true
positive rate. The intuition of false negative
rate is among all heart failure patients,
what percentage of those patients is missed by the
predicting model? False positive rate is the ratio
between false positive and the condition negative.
The intuition of false positive rate is to measure
among all people without heart failure, what
percentage of them is incorrectly predicted by
the model as to have heart failure?
Finally, true negative rate or specificity
is the number of true negative divided by
the ground truth condition negative, which
also equals 1 minus false positive rate.
The intuition behind true negative rate is to
find among all people without heart failure,
what percentage of them is correctly
classified as non-heart failure patients?
Note that accuracy measures the combination
performance of true positive and true negative,
while true positive rate measures the performance
only about true positive, and true negative rate
measures the performance only about true negative.
It is often possible to obtain high performance
on a single metrics such as accuracy,
while it's difficult to obtain high performance on
all metrics. That's why we often test a predictive
model against multiple metrics. First of all,
different metrics are designed for different
situations. It is important to choose the
proper metric for your prediction study.